he said England would have a contact
tracing app by mid-may instead in
mid-june this happened our app won't
work because Apple won't change their
system so we've agreed to join forces
with Google and Apple to bring the best
bits of both systems together the
problem was that Apple wouldn't give
government access their systems unless
they agreed to apples rules on data my
sources tell me there was a real anger
in the Department of Health about this
but also that after Matt Hancock were
finished speaking someone from Downing
Street called Apple to apologize and in
a way that sums up the entire government
approach this app on one hand lots of
big talk on the other hand no real clear
plan but where exactly they're going
Apple says it helped the government at
all levels and Department of Health
sources say the relationship is
excellent but in other countries like
Italy the move to Apple and Google's
technology came almost as soon as it was
released it was completely obvious and a
no-brainer because the issues we had
with the other technology was so
substantial that we thought they really
undermine the effectiveness of the
product it would still be a new
potential useful product if you have
nothing better you go for it but with
this much more powerful and you know
reliable underlying engine let's say it
was absolutely obvious instead of
switching the UK government pressed
ahead launching a trial here on the Isle
of Wight a member of the app's ethics
advisory board speaking exclusively to
Sky News says the trial wasn't set up to
produce reliable information I think it
was set up in emergency situation
without a very clear idea of what
problem they were trying to solve and
how you know and there was this idea
really early on I think particularly
driven perhaps by Matt Hancock's
interest in apps and perhaps Dominic
Cummings interest in data who knows that
an app would do it and that would be the
magic bullet the government says the
trial on the Isle of Wight was a success
a Department of Health and Social Care
spokesperson said the NHS covered 19 app
has undergone some of the most rigorous
testing in the world our aim is that it
will help users engage with every
aspects of the existing NHS test and
trade service which is successfully up
and running with no timeline there's no
certainty England will ever have an app
meanwhile northern earns one based on
Google Apple's technology is set to be
ready by the end of the month Elemental
Sky News